[Música]
Pedro Castillo Busca asilo en México el
expresidente peruano ratificó su
solicitud según el canciller mexicano
Marcelo ebrard esto mientras dentro de
Perú avanza el proceso judicial en
contra de Castillo el ex mandatario es
acusado de asestar un auto golpe de
estado por disolver el congreso y
ordenar la reorganización del sistema
judicial hoy la justicia le ordenó siete
días de prisión preventiva
Rusia y Estados Unidos intercambiaron
prisioneros así la basquetbolista
pudo viajar de regreso a Washington
después de estar detenida diez meses en
Moscú a cambio El Traficante de armas
ruso Víctor Wood volvió a su país natal
Croacia entra a la zona a partir del
primero de enero de 2023 mientras a grem
celebra el aval de la comisión europea
para la libre circulación rumania y
Bulgaria siguen a la espera de ser
aceptados esta vez Austria vetó su
aspiración
buenas noches y bienvenidos a la
actualidad internacional aquí en France
24 yo soy María Clara calle y es un
gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en Perú la justicia de ese
país ordenó siete días de prisión
preventiva para el expresidente Pedro
Castillo mientras se realiza su juicio
en el que lo acusan de rebelión el
exmandatario intentó disolver el
congreso y refugiarse en la Embajada
Mexicana en Lima pero la policía lo
detuvo antes de llegar aún así este
jueves el canciller mexicano Marcelo
ebrard confirmó que Castillo ratificó la
solicitud de asilo el embajador de
México en Lima Pablo Monroy se reunió
con Castillo Andrés granadillo nos
amplía
Castillo ratifica su solicitud de asilo
a México así lo informó el canciller
mexicano Marcelo ebrard desde su cuenta
de Twitter tras publicar la carta formal
de pedido el embajador Pablo Monroy me
reporta desde Lima que pudo
entrevistarse a las 13 y 20 horas con
Pedro Castillo en el centro
penitenciario lo encontró bien
físicamente y en compañía de su abogado
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pidió garantías para
Castillo entonces
nosotros pedimos que este se le respeten
sus derechos humanos que se actúe
con
legalidad verdadera
se protege a su familia más temprano en
Perú la corte ordenó siete días de
detención antes del juicio en su contra
por el presunto delito de rebelión se le
acusa por su intento de disolver El
Congreso cerrar la fiscalía y Llamar a
un gobierno de emergencia con toque de
queda y pedido de elecciones sin apoyo
de sus ministros el ejército las
autoridades judiciales el episodio
terminó con su arresto y la posesión de
su vicepresidenta Dina boluarte como
nueva dirigente de Perú la primera mujer
en asumir este cargo de momento boluarte
descartó elecciones anticipadas Yo sé
que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones esta estamos viendo
alternativas Mientras tanto en Lima se
mantienen algunas manifestaciones de
partidarios de Pedro Castillo que piden
su Liberación y acusan a la nueva
presidenta de traición
la wnb a la liga de baloncesto femenina
y profesional de Estados Unidos celebró
la liberación de la basquetbolista
Britney wriner la doble medallista
olímpica estaba en una prisión en Rusia
desde febrero por transportar un
vaporizador de cannabis algo que es
legal en Estados Unidos a cambio de que
moscúla dejar en libertad Washington
accedió a soltar a Víctor Wood uno de
los mayores traficantes de armas y quien
desde 2012 había sido sentenciado por un
tribunal estadounidense Wood ya está en
Rusia y grainer está volando hacia
Washington veamos las reacciones
en este vídeo de los servicios de
seguridad rusos aparece con paso pesado
antes de sonreír en unas horas Britney
grainer estará en casa tras nueve meses
detenida
no me lo esperaba pero bueno es el mejor
regalo de Navidad
Hoy estamos muy agradecidos Más allá del
baloncesto esto es muy emotivo No suelo
ser una persona emotiva pero estoy
abrumada
fue detenida el pasado febrero en un
aeropuerto de Moscú con un vaporizador y
un líquido que contenía Cannabis que es
ilegal en Rusia la justicia de ese país
la condenó a nueve años de cárcel tras
meses de prisión preventiva la estrella
del baloncesto fue liberada a cambio de
Víctor vouch Traficante de armas ruso
encarcelado desde hace 10 años en
Estados Unidos El llamado mercader de la
muerte Ya llegó a su país y fue recibido
por su esposa y su madre mientras la
salida de gregler no deja de ser
polémica Pues el estadounidense Paul
welland detenido en Rusia durante más de
cuatro años por presuntos actos de
espionaje sigue en prisión por desgracia
había que elegir entre traer a Britney a
casa o no traer a nadie
Moscú y Washington se acusan mutuamente
de retener prisioneros con fines
políticos tensiones que sean exacerbado
desde la invasión rusa de Ucrania
cambiamos de noticia y nos vamos a medio
oriente Porque Irán dijo que ejecutó a
un preso condenado por un delito
presuntamente cometido durante las
protestas que ha habido tras la muerte
de maxa a mini esta joven falleció en
septiembre bajo custodia de la policía
de la moral aquella sería la primera
pena de muerte que ordena Teherán en el
contexto de las protestas la persona fue
sentenciada por bloquear una calle y
presuntamente atacar a un miembro de las
fuerzas de seguridad con un machete
activistas denuncian que al menos otros
12 detenidos también se enfrentan a la
pena de muerte por participar en el
levantamiento social mientras que la
agencia de noticias de Derechos Humanos
asegura que más de 450 personas han
muerto en los disturbios y que al menos
18.000 han sido contenidas desde el
inicio de las protestas
el presidente chino y el príncipe
heredero de Arabia Saudita acordaron la
firma de alianzas de energía e
infraestructura por unos 30.000 millones
de dólares Ese fue el resultado del
encuentro en el primer día de alto nivel
de Esta visita que ha fruncido el ceño
de Estados Unidos y es que china Busca
impulsar su economía ralentizada por la
pandemia al tiempo que fortalece lazos
con el país árabe que ha sido un gran
Aliado de Estados Unidos y que además es
el mayor exportador de petróleo del
mundo entre tanto otros líderes árabes
empezaron a llegar allí para asistir a
una Cumbre con el presidente chino
sostendrá conversaciones con los seis
miembros del Consejo de cooperación del
Golfo
y Croacia comenzará a ser parte de la
zona schengen desde el primero de enero
de 2023 según lo aprobó este jueves la
comisión europea esto significa que las
personas que viajen desde aquel país al
resto de las 26 naciones que conforman
el área schengen no necesitarán que les
verifiquen su identidad ni cumplir con
requisitos especiales para transportarse
sin embargo rumania y Bulgaria no
obtuvieron este aval
es oficial a partir del primero de enero
Croacia entrará en el espacio schengen
una noticia celebrada especialmente por
la presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea
Croacia realmente ha hecho todo lo
posible para ser parte del espacio
schengen y estamos convencidos de que es
un mensaje muy positivo para todos los
ciudadanos europeos
ahora los ciudadanos de los estados
schengen podrán entrar y salir de
Croacia sin controles fronterizos la
candidatura de zagreb fue aceptada por
unanimidad por los ministros del
interior de los 27 países que conforman
la unión pero no todos celebran la
reunión de este 8 de diciembre en
Bélgica rumania y Bulgaria también
aspiraban a formar parte del espacio
schengen pero no contaban con el veto de
Austria que teme que los flujos
migratorios aumenten si estos dos países
entran en el acuerdo
Austria tiene más de 100.000 cruces
fronterizos ilegales de los cuales
75.000 no están registrados y esto a
pesar de ser un país sin salida al mar y
en medio de los países schengen Entonces
el ya no está funcionando lo que
significa que tenemos que mejorarlo
significativamente primero
críticas infundadas según otros
gobiernos europeos y en particular
Rumanía
bucarest considera que cumplieron todas
las condiciones para entrar en la zona
de libre circulación
lamentamos si realmente no entendemos la
posición inflexible de Austria
durante el año pasado Rumanía ha
demostrado ser un actor de pleno derecho
en la seguridad Europea
securitas y europea una seguridad
europea que los 27 creen que está en
peligro mientras aumentan las llegadas
irregulares la ruta migratoria de los
balcanes occidentales representa la
mayor parte del aumento con casi 140.000
entradas desde principios de año
el canciller Alemán olafones se
pronunció un día después de que las
autoridades frustraron los planes de un
golpe de estado contra el Boom de stack
25 personas pertenecientes a una red de
extremistas de derecha fueron detenidas
este miércoles
de lo contrario la consecuencia más
importante es que todos sepan que
tenemos un estado que se puede defender
somos una democracia que se puede
defender que puede frustrar esas
violaciones de la ley esa planificación
con sus autoridades de seguridad y puede
defenderse con su fuerza así llegamos al
final de las noticias pero los invitamos
a que sigan con France 24
[Música]